if you're going to work dressing like a
hooker all right if you're going to work
acting like a hooker can we really blame
the men if they get confused and think
maybe you're kind of loose you know it's
like it's like women will dress so
provocatively and then get mad if men do
anything it's like
it's just craziness and women should
have repercussions for falsely accusing
men of crimes no I do not think this
will lead to women that really were
raped and really were assaulted to not
come forward I think women that these
terrible things have happened to will
have evidence on their side to prove
this kind of thing and I think there
needs to be a push for laws to be passed
that make the definitions very clear and
less subjective and also get laws passed
where there are repercussions for women
falsely accusing men I